can't we see it can't be nothing so
easily guessing nothing yeah right for
Mount Fuji you right you ready to climb
some mountains today uh yeah cuz all I
really have a choice
getting ready and we were just given the
news from talking Michael set at Mount
Fuji it's gonna be fourteen degrees
Fahrenheit so gonna be like snowing I
don't think anyone in this trip prepared
for that kind of weather so we're taking
like all of our jackets like everything
warm that we packed or grating yeah we
checked it like weather reports of Tokyo
and it said like 30 to 40 degrees
Fahrenheit now that would be the coldest
which is Oh like we can layer up and
that's you know easy to withstand on
Mount Fuji though I'll see how we I
don't know it is but it's mMmmm
aqueducts booyaka don that's Japanese
for mom and daughter something for mom
and son mom and son is delicious chicken
egg so it's the two together more vids
no but that's I think that's a proper
timer that is super morbid with like
mommy and daughter it over right
Isaac I do like riding the trains in
Tokyo you had a good time having a party
it's called a TM explore their ever
feeling that say like for my first to be
my own son like experience energy
consumption
are you excited for Mount Fuji
mother is terrible what are we looking
at
so we're looking at Mount Fuji it's only
up there and you can see that you know
can you park the car you can actually
not see anything
you know it sucks so my favorite teacher
of all time although my third grade
teacher she has studied here like abroad
and ever since third grade
and I come here the famous look at least
we're here shout to metric you're on a
mountain Isaac you know that does it
feel like you're on a mountain no that's
the best view we're gonna get oh you're
smoking nothing here little too young to
smoke oh you shouldn't be smoking
recently oh you're a bad kid are you bad
kid smoky god breaks my heart
break my heart eyes it's okay when I was
a kid when I used to do this a lot if it
was cold outside if you're like yeah I
skewed a lot I don't do that I used to
do that when I was today
yeah yes oh that was great
all right so you wrote this bus for like
freakin like two hours and we're only
here for 20 minutes if you don't see
anything at all this is fantastic you
want to be like Bart we grow up yeah
it's a really quick way to do that is to
take off all your clothes right now
Bart is walking around naked look at
this guy you refuse to accept the fact
that it's really cold out here I mean a
hundred people walking around jackets
and scarves and she could have you
talked about it being cold maybe the bus
is really warm and keep you charged up
now that could be out here if I can
holler up on a dime there your ears cold
your fingertips cold you know the cold
fast yeah your nose your fire
all right now this incredibly awesome
journey to Mount Fuji that last 20
minutes has given us another short
amount of time to finish our lunch so we
got shrimp tempura some sort Incan
pepper thing with some pasta some
potatoes some of that crap and some of
that crap and some of that crap it's
tiny pushing David why are you scared
because I have a deathly see how many
were in that I think all the children in
there and that's how good they are
because they're young we have an
experience like I have I have
experienced a high is Isaac open baby
yeah you better watch out when I start
in the stomach what the wires just going
to nothing right now licking his face
right now
he looks like already get it done
we're being rebels
and we're walking away from the group
and we're venturing well here's one oh
this is sick is that the pressure we're
going on honey
this is all we get to see of you just 20
feet out in all directions but theme or
fiction came with us he wanted to say be
lame I know what would you do is that
guy started moving oh if that's a real
person just standing still that's a
really big person pack [ __ ] we're really
friendly and this one's got balls to
there no they don't get neutered here
this one's got balls for days balls for
days look at that guy hey you're so
friendly you're so friendly why do you
guys not have tails oh we got another
one the way their tails look though
looks like it's supposed to be like that
it's like a bob a tail like it doesn't
like it's cut off how thick it is I
named him whiskers you don't want to
leave us alone with the other ones
following to following us we walked away
and I kept following us they're like
these people know cats you know we own
two
keep hurting so loud you know probably
going on the fire [ __ ]
jzuk sparrow captain Isaac Sparrow to De
Vito just a straight out of Ruby man
how was your experience being a pirate
for a day it was good you like being a
pirate
no Coco why don't you like me in a part
to cold
all right so we're about to walk up
these 89 steps any ice test 91 steps I
forgot we had to purify ourselves in
order to go up the steps are you just
pure fighter When in Rome right you feel
cleaner yeah baby this is a sacred
ritual we're paying our respects we're
here tired it Isaac did it gonna be bad
look if someone has someone else's
wishes that's like a tricky cheese and
the animatronics to come out to play the
music yeah
holy tree what is a bullet train so it's
a train that they have you're in Japan
that goes really fast like that
then you have that we had the toy
version of that what would you do we
just what I said yesterday it toy bullet
train
pretty cool really into right a real
[ __ ] that's happening
right the doors are closed locked be
careful we are gonna go now old cos it's
dangerous right now in front of a
station so they're not going to go over
200 miles per hour right now does it
feel fasten Isaac all right so Brandon
what are we eating we are gonna eat came
in which is dipping ramen noodles one
mole another bowl is this big pork sauce
dip it in the sauces local way you
prefer this dipping ramen or regular
ramen I think the dipping lemon
woo-hoo-hoo-hoo is a long line for a
reason that's true leave it in line for
like 10 minutes maybe and line up
wrapped around the building they always
say that best for these places with
lines true dat I just got a bib for you
bro that's cool
nice my hair is only my crew it's
literally my bib and I always pitch put
in my heart then I go home in the night
our don't wonder when I cuddle with you
I get hungry your hair toxic because I
don't like you
all you gotta do is get it in a spoon
and use that as your support system I
fail so hard who doesn't that's good
just lerp it he has to slurp it yummy
now I could be a brand and brand I was
saying how the noodles come out cold and
then you make it warm by putting in
those sauce but the sauce starts to get
cold too okay so I just eaten cold stuff
so that's the only critique half
otherwise so the flavor is on point you
know and I literally eating on it before
even having a moment
I'm like they like a free slur yeah I
told them was so cute nice ice cream
with chips ice cream which hips I know
I'm gonna be that ho last week salty
play that everybody enjoys really I
think it's ballin like a brand new space
everyone here thinks is really good
except you unsophisticated tastebuds